STEPHANIE WONG:
Hey, everyone, I've
just opened up my
awesome new hipster store
called Conventional Obscurity.
I've set up my website
and all my services
are running in Kubernetes.
But I don't know how
to manage my traffic.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, I've
got a solution for you.
But you've probably
never heard of it.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK,
what is it called?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
It's called Istio,
and it's a service
match for Kubernetes
that lets you set up networking
between your services.
STEPHANIE WONG: Sounds
like that's pretty useful.
Can you show me how it works?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Sure thing.
Let's jump into a demo.
So let's first familiarize
ourselves with Istio.
An Istio service
mesh is logically
split into a data plane
and a control plane.
The data plane is made up of
intelligent proxies called
on y's that are deployed as
side cars with micro services.
The control plane manages
the proxies to route traffic,
and it is made up
of three components.
A mixer is a platform
independent component,
and it enforces access
control and usage policies
across the service mesh.
A pilot provides
service discovery
for on y proxies and side
cars, traffic management,
and resiliency.
A citadel provides the security
components, service to service,
and end user authentication.
Let's look at this with
a real world example.
We have our hipster
app, which comprises
of about 11 to 12
micro services that are
made in different languages.
Now here's our hipster store
website built with Kubernetes.
Let's add a few
items to the cart.
A vintage typewriter,
and I like this camera.
Let's add them to the
cart and place our order.
We've completed our order
with the shipping and tracking
confirmation IDs.
Now let's see what this looks
like into the Google Cloud
Platform console.
I have a single cluster
running in Kubernetes.
It's a fairly small cluster.
Here I have some
workloads, as you can see.
In the cart service,
there's a checkout service,
and then as you
scroll down, you also
see Istio independent
services as well
that are deployed there.
And if you go into
one of the services,
we're going to click
on checkout service.
You can see the CPU, memory,
and disk utilizations
and we're going to click
into one of the managed
pods for the checkout
service, and you'll
see as you scroll down that
there is an Istio proxy that's
installed within there,
and what that means is this
is a transparent side
car that's running
co-located within
that cart service.
These are all the services
that were deployed.
Now here at this point,
you can see the end points,
and where you can access
these services with their IP
address and the ports.
And that's it.
To summarize, we saw
an overview of Istio,
a live Kubernetes cluster
with multiple microservices,
and Istio side cars installed.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now I can
see why Istio is so hot.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Just by using Istio,
you can manage your
Kubernetes services easily
and make your website cool.
Don't forget to like,
comment, and subscribe
for our next episode on Istio.
STEPHANIE WONG: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]